Well,
the,
um,
I was born in 1934 and the,
as you're right,
the depression was on a,
I think I am a,
I can legitimately consider myself a,
a,
a child of the depression and that,
uh,
nobody had anything.
And so when you're not used to having
something,
when you do have something,
you appreciate it a lot more.
Um,
and because everybody was in the same
boat,
there was also a kind of an affinity of,
of misery and,
uh,
and as a consequence,
there was no mystery.
In other words,
if everybody's suffering the same way,
the same thing.
There was a kind of,
we're all in this together and I felt
that with my,
uh,
as a kid and I'm a.
and then World War Two came and I,
uh,
we lived in Kansas in Wichita,
Kansas where they built the b seventeens
and the [inaudible].
My mother in fact worked on the assembly
line of the b 29 as a wire cutter and
the Boeing plant in Wichita and a world
war two.
And we thought that the Japanese were
going to bomb us any moment because we
had the Boeing plant,
there was after Pearl Harbor.
But what,
what it,
what it did for me is,
uh,
the war was,
was a very present,
even though it was physically very,
very far away.
It was very much a part of our lives.
And,
uh,
my dad had been a,
a,
a moraine and the 19 twenties,
uh,
I decided right then and there that
someday I would grow up to be a marine
and so did my older brother.
And as a matter of fact,
that's what happened.
But it,
all that stuff kind of began there.
That,
that here again,
the World War II was similar in,
in,
uh,
to the depression and that there was a
togetherness about it.
And it wasn't a,
it wasn't him and her and they,
them.
And they was all of us at war.
All of us doing the best we could to,
uh,
to beat the bad guys and to protect
ourselves from the bad guys.
And,
um,
there was,
uh,
so I,
I think frankly,
um,
I am fortunate,
I know it sounds strange,
but I am fortunate that I did have the
depression and World War II and those
early years.
Um,
because it,
uh,
I,
I never,
ever,
because of those two experiences,
a day to day experiences in both cases,
I have never ever been somebody who took
anything for granted because,
uh,
because I just,
it was part of my growing up and part of
my formation is who I am today.
I think that,
uh,
it all began with,
you know,
wondering where we were going to have
enough money to have dinner tonight.
Whether or not somebody's next to me or
some member of my family was going to
die in a war.
It made everything.
It heightened everything,
heightened awareness,
heightened interest,
heightened intensity of life.
And I still feel that.